ce prix qui votent style autour de la
table si vous deviez partir un mois sur
une île déserte avec un des garçons ou
une femme à lui jean michel mr nobody
il faut l'écouter sur europe 1 alors
allons y est revenue au rouge
oui c'est moi de vous imiter là mais
j'aime beaucoup ça va ça vous va très
bien toujours amoureuse oui ça se voit
c'est ce cri qui pot de style autour de
la table si vous deviez partir un mois
sur une île déserte avec un des garçons
ou une femme à l'huile et bien jean
michel maire lui ça va être entre vous
et matthieu delormeau le premier arrivé
à deux points d'accord à 2 le dentiste
d'enora mais deux jours pour lui soigner
une dent un non mais ça va les gars les
vannes
combien de temps va-t-il mettre pour lui
soigner ses 134 dont way 268 bah bravo 2
à notre besoin vous foutez toujours la
gueule des politiques mais si vous
deviez choisir un gouvernement pourra
dîner et plus si affinités vous
prendriez qui a quand tu vas directe en
cas de oui à toi tu te fais pas chier le
président c'est tout nté aidant philippe
j'aime bien web apps à bakel les tous et
lotta va nous faire tout le gouvernement
alors il loue les parties du jeu
aa à aa une war je n'aurais pas eu d'eau
à l'est pas du tout un voyou pas kader
adore la merguez sachant qu'il lui en
faut 8 par jour
combien mon style en une semaine kader
c'est lui qui a des bras
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que tu étais première de la
classe a rejeté dans les cinq premiers
mais bavardaient away mais c'était
toujours ben hammam trop bas la baisse
et sa profonde dire monsieur je suis pas
d'accord ah ouais
ah oui j'aurais que c'était la rebelle
de l'équipe mais anne roumanoff elle tu
as fait quoi comme études déjà j'ai fait
sciences po lesquels voyant balle à sion
la science de la peau tu as fait des
blue jackets au prix plutôt brun au
blond griotto trouver un nom alors je
vais vous dire je connais je connais les
femmes elle a pas trouée mais elle a des
délires aux soins des sms
elle reçoit des watts alors qu'est-ce
qui fait ce soir un goûter un avis je
vous raconte pas sa vie tant pis mais
sommet en direct bah oui on dirait quand
il y en a parfois semblé fait une
émission de télé en fait une fois je me
suis fait draguer par un prof on avait
froid 7 à sciences po donc j'étais major
aussi et il m'a donné sa veste qui
sentait un parfum que je trouvais
érotique
non oui bon ben voilà donc juste ça et
après il m'a appelé c'est pas un peu
j'aurais voulu me proposer les sujets un
truc j'ai pas donné suite je trouvais ça
bizarre pourquoi il voulait donner les
sujets à l'avancé ce serait bien qu'on
se voie pour qu'on parle des sujets sur
lesquels était quand même assez vieux
parce que je pense qu'il avait au moins
40 ans ouais enfin vente en saisissant
youssouf vous l'êtes plus chaud bah oui
je crois
rétrospectivement parce que j'avais pas
d'expérience on va le trouver ont valeur
[Musique]